yeah welcome to this video at a slight
technical problem and there for 20
seconds late it's a 15-minute game
against an opponent probably from Spain
you've never one hundred percent Sean
it's got 1,900 rating and the caro-kann
I have made this video series on icc in
german language sure web I'm looking
Knight f6 and Bishop f5 our goal at f6
and take with the Jeep on the soccer
Braunstein last variation I was
surprised that this is actually a very
much playable line it is some nowadays
rather uncommon but there's no no big
issue c3 9525 is one of them interesting
points I have you in every yeah this is
a very direct approach the kind of value
higher rated I want to exchange
everything that moves filling in the
position ok the question is should I
exchange on f3 or should I let him take
because i think it's relatively likely
that he will take anyway on d5 hmm
yeah yeah you can think about let's say
push up at five and tending Bishop you
fall and then let him let him exchange
or do I want to take let's let's finish
up at five it's not it's not bad anyway
and spending too much time was probably
not not warranted yeah as soon suspected
he exchanged yeah this is interesting
this check
one knight c6 young but ok 96 there if
he takes it so it's really a bad form of
exchanging pieces so Bishop d7 also was
was a possibility not not bad at all but
this is better of course why not develop
the night ooh good square
hmm well maybe 97 also had its points97
with the intention to to go to be 6
later with the night be six to see for
can often be am a good way to to use
this piece night 32
yeah night to g3 may be as high as his
idea but let's say I play six let's play
a play a very very direct game Nia just
attacked us this Bishop and it cannot
retreat to d3 anymore at five you should
control the square he more or less needs
to go to a form
I can take but the Sun giving me half
then gives me the bishop BAM this cannot
really be an threatening so is there any
point in going to 2 D 3 or should I
place the bishop somewhere else
instantly of somewhere else meaning to
g6 maybe it's not it's not so clear cut
to the g6 is really a good scram
it's not a bad square but it's not not
clear what the bishop is doing one g6 it
sort of it controls this long diagonal
but this is an empty diagonal there's no
peace on them so should be 7s maybe also
possibility
on on Bishop g6 he might go F form I
dropped back here and somehow like this
the square mall it might get in trouble
on g6 and it doesn't it doesn't do so
much this this Bishop okay just take the
hub of them have opened file and then
intent to go rook g4 at some point using
the fourth-ranked so here actually it's
one point where I can use it Bishop e3
and then play a five
all the way back I was more thinking
about III but it's it's probably a
probably fine to go to d2 so how to make
progress ave e 5v5 actually gives her
this Bishop move some sense putting
something on Yvonne and obtaining
pressure yeah yeah c'mon really castling
I need to rock on yet item it's not not
much on to do about that I need to
record yet yes
ah maybe to g6 all right come on let's
go to g6 why not
h3 is actually rather questionable move
I mean and sort of provoked him into
into playing this thing is with the porn
on h3 you cannot play a form which
otherwise would have been something to
consider effort to stop the movie 5 this
is not not one here
yeah maybe you should go be sure that
form
trying to prevent you five with them
with peace
I don't see a clear refutation of this
move at the moment
should that form
I can think of playing c5 of course
Bishop f4 c5 and if it takes a five run
it's not exactly a spectacular
but well anyway doesn't you need to play
play Bishop f4 I mean allowing you five
it's um it's probably not advisable
you know the only other move that might
make some sense as to to play Bishop
rookie to like doubling on the e-file
that's that's the only idea I'm coming
up with here for white yeah he went for
it but okay he five was the idea anyway
and now Bishop p6 right or you form this
is the question directly you form but
now then Bishop f4 okay let's let's play
this son the batter wolf
so on young blacks got two bishops got a
center first you would think okay this
must be just be excellent for black but
I don't think it is so clear I cannot
take on d for ages are hanging I can't
play before but if I play if or there's
always the possibility of night h 52 f 4
on night h5 Bishop f4 of course at the
moment yeah g2 is saying but f6 is also
hang so I was trying to get to this
point no he played the the critical
looking move so taking on g2 he will
take on f6 and this is really bad right
yeah okay can i do that if i play for
Bishop f4 as it's also excellent
probably for white I mean okay excellent
Bishop f4 i can i can drop all the way
back to f8 and it's not it's not
entirely clear
is he threatening something by the way
Knight f6 Rock f6d texty fiber can play
would be six winning winning a PCM okay
Knight f6 is no threat at least yeah
this is annoying this pressure you for
Bishop f4 dropping all the way back from
gym yeah but it's not dad's I don't
really want to play that haha what about
c5 increasing increasing pressure
f4 f4 I play you form I'm not clear on
very complicated position yeah but that
that's the kind of struggle blackest is
aiming for with done the night f6d takes
f6 maneuver ha by the way if I go with C
5 you might take on e5 and play Knight
f4 and I know I can capture this is just
an exchange add you just exchange the
pieces okay come on play c5 I didn't
really spend enough time on this but I
need to I need to move at some point
my idea is some to exchange on d4c takes
d4 see takes d4 and then maybe Bishop f5
f5 to d3 King be seven groups yet this
kind of maneuvers or maybe Bishop to b5
also I'm a possibility this is actually
really good there should be five it's a
good additional idea simply also because
this Bishop then is out of range of the
night in case it would take on f6 so
after let's say Bishop b5 rookie 3 if I
take at some point on g2 Knight f6 isn't
attacking both pieces so I can just move
away the rook and the night down it's
not doing so much maybe depends on the
concrete position but moving the the
bishop away from this having a certainly
a good thing aha he intends to to fix
the pawn cm
so let's let's take here first
so Bishop to b5 on something else let's
put it on b5
yeah this also means that his
coordination is somewhat off now maybe
now we can take on f6 hmm maybe yeah
should have thought a bit longer but
neither of six okay it's not happening
yeah just take with the porn and must
but now he better has some very direct
way to to attack me otherwise this is
really bogus exchanging maybe he wants
to play a form Oh something entirely
different I didn't think about that at
all but is it is it really a problem Jim
f7 porn
it's not so clear that this is really
dangerous yeah okay is also preparing
Knight to f6
hmmm kinky 694 hmm
as fastest check and then see how to
continue maybe I'm yeah King in seven I
was trying the same but well he will
play King do you one now I guess can be
one home doesn't make much sense I think
kini one that's a kinky one and that
King e7 was my idea but going on the
e-file ism yeah nothing you especially
like to do directly opposed to the look
on you want
yeah I just said I don't think this is
logical but he played it anyway yeah
maybe it is it it's okay i don't know so
what's happening
the I have seven kingi seven years also
night f4 attacking the rook and to d5
with check hmm what about just going
going for it Eve for Luke f7 and then
I've got to look I got Bishop d3 check
and Bishop e5 moves like that it is
something it's not clear if it is enough
but it is something
I have an interesting idea what if I
play f5 here f5 rook takes a special d3
and if the pawn takes I just move the
rock somewhere somewhere active
somewhere good is there man I move the
rookies got 90 f6 check that's I don't
have a good I don't have a good post for
this rook otherwise this would have been
a really cool idea I do not have a
square for the rook
I don't know cannot move the King I'll
Sam that's a bit bit annoying here maybe
rook come on a playbook evade just
protect this if he goes Knight f6 I must
play King e6 whatever and let him take
on age 7 now it's not the move 5 I
especially wanted to play but I didn't
have a good idea really maybe there was
some selective interesting idea but i
didn't i didn't find it didn't find it
yeah my dad to go only if all this is
really crap but what can you do now
night h7 i go Rupe jade and hope that
this night doesn't does it have a good
escape
yeah 96
slow night here night of six and
continue from there right
so if or unfortunately I'm not really
attacking anything just oh just bloody
pin on the EVO
yeah from a technical point of view this
position look some very really shaky
with the king and on the e-file in the
middle of the board and so on long term
I'm not so so afraid here if I don't I
don't go down instantly then this
position is quite okay it's two bishops
and some center play it's not not so
clear it's it's porn down with our
pieces film I active on black side and
two bishops this is really nice yeah
maybe here trying to take on g5 I don't
know
yeah Bishop takes g5 I'm not so sure how
how is going to prevent that probably at
technically bishops III or something
Mary now not sure that this is really so
great either just move the rook
somewhere h5 oh yeah should these
results or not completely convincing
yeah he doesn't move I did so it's a
difficult position no no question but at
some point you and you need to speed up
I mean I'm really I'm really slow and so
on but this is a two much here what he's
doing okay this move after all so I'm
how to continue now look I can also be
are not look to see a this is really
stupid look here problem one point is
after Bishop f6 it's maybe possible to
sacrifice the exchange really like rook
H takes g5 yeah because look I'll do
that now I'm I don't invest time
knowledge that just put this on the
board it's quite quite interesting here
now I've got f5 coming f5 and both
bishops are so strong against a
completely stupid night and yeah this is
Bishop b4 you coming
right but it's a very huge compensation
we can we can look at this a bit
afterwards it's really an exchange down
but i think it's it's close to full
compensation now it's it's just just to
win and deform
yeah he's sort of lost ur probably lost
his nerve or something it wasn't it
wasn't such a big deal this position he
has I'm really curious let's see what
the computer says who gives me a really
big advantage I mean I suspected that
that I must be all right but it always
looks shaky on the e-file this kind of
rookie one King e6a it looks it looks
somewhat weird but it also yeah it's
difficult to find them I'm just
threatening to take g5 and if i restore
material equality it's it's a great
position with two bishops and adults or
everything centralized and playing in
the center you know look aged 5 and now
computer as as usual very very simple
chassis a bishop before this wins an
exchange instead of sacrificing one and
therefore it is better than my move of
course here look this is attacked and it
needs to stay on the e-file because of
this rope so and winning an exchange but
I actually sacrificed him myself and
okay this is neat the computer gives
here with an old exchanged our computers
are on a two-pound advantage for black
so it sees that this is overwhelming
really so probably it is also
technically overwhelming I only thought
that that strategically this must be
great with those pawns rolling ignore
them those pawns to bishops and his
pawns are really not dangerous and he's
got an absolutely stupid night so let's
say something like this computer once
ago Bishop c5 I would have played this
probably just just going for some hear
something like this some positional
compensation and this is really intime
een you can even think about sacrificing
next exchange King see one computer
suggestion and even second nother one
yeah minus three and you win with the
bishops and three connected passes yeah
this is very often the type of position
that black can can get because you which
is mrs. G takes f6 you increase your
sensual influence and you get very
complicated middle games this is the
idea of this line to imbalance the
structure and get a fighting position
this is certainly a great position to
play if you want to want to fight get an
interesting game yeah thanks for
watching